Hi, I'm Erik Voss, and Game of Thrones
season 7 is coming, and it looks like
we're going to get some huge payoff in
these final episodes. But it's easy to
forget that there are actually a lot of
unresolved questions and mysteries that
Game of Thrones still needs to explain.
Some are interesting implications of
recent bombshells and others are
lingering, loose ends or bizarre moments
from the past that no one ever really
followed up on. So in this video, I'm
going to talk about the biggest
questions and ways that the show might
answer them. And spoiler warning, just in
case any of my predictions or theories
end up coming true. Okay, let's start with
Jon Snow. We now know that he is half
Targaryen - the son of Ned Stark's sister,
Lyanna, and the Prince Rhaegar Targaryen.
So the question is what exactly does
that Targaryen lineage mean for him now?
So, if Lyanna and Rhaegar were married,
that would make Jon, in a way, heir to the
Iron Throne. At least using the argument
that Daenerys is using, that Robert
Baratheon was an illegitimate usurper
and that the throne still legally
belongs to the Targaryen dynasty.
And if Jon is a non-bastard son of the
crown prince of that dynasty, his claim
to the throne is even slightly stronger
than Daenerys'. So if this truth
becomes public knowledge, will that hurt
Daenerys' campaign to reclaim the
throne? And will that make her and Jon
enemies? Not to say that Jon wants the
Iron Throne, but will Daenerys see him as
a threat? Or looking at things more
optimistically since they're family now,
will their bloodlines bring them closer
together? And in the eyes of the reigning
monarch, Cersei, will this now be a second
Targaryen orphan that she has to face on
the battlefield? Meanwhile from another
perspective, if Jon''s Targaryen
background becomes public in the north,
will that make it an enemy to his fellow
northerners? Remember, all these northern
Lords and their families followed the
Starks into a war against the Targaryens.
I could see this creating some tension.
Remember, little Lady Lyanna Mormont
and the rest swore fealty to Jon on the
basis that Ned Stark's blood runs
through his veins, and yeah, even though
he still has Stark blood from his mother,
Lyanna, maybe these northerners will be
sticklers about it. Da King a da Norf? Wait wait... you got Lyanna's blood?
And dragon blood?! We have no king! Really I'm
just curious to know what Jon's real
name is. It was hard to read Lyanna's lips
in that season finale scene. It looks
like it began with an
a sound, so I'm guessing maybe some
Targaryen a name like Aegon, or Aemon or
Aerys. We've also speculated that could
it be Jaehaerys, which would connect Jon to
an interesting parallel figure in the
Targaryen family history. Actually check
out our season finale breakdown for more
information on that, but let me know in
the comments - do you think Jon's
Targaryen blood will get thim in trouble?
And let's move on to Bran. So what the
hell can Bran do exactly? So last season
revealed that Bran now has the powers
of the three-eyed Raven. He can connect
with weirwood trees to glimpse into
moments in the past, like the Kingslayer
moment, or in the future, like wildfire
destroying the sept. But the mystery here
lies in whether or not Bran is able to
change those events. So remember in the
heartbreaking hold the door episode,
Bran warged into Hodor's mind as a
boy, making him hold the door in the
present day so they could escape, and
this choice by Bran proved to be the
origin of Hodor constantly mumbling the
nonsense word of Hodor throughout his
life. And then in another time jump, when
Bran looked at the Tower of joy, he
called out to his father and Ned turned
around as if he heard. So does this
mean that Bran has the power to change
the past? Or, sounding like a real time
travel nerd for a second, has Bran
already changed some things in the past?
Like maybe at some point in the future,
he will go back to cause things that
have already happened.
I talked previously about the theories
of Bran turning the Mad King mad, for
example, whispering the phrase burn
them all to him. Also the idea that Bran
Stark could be the ancient Bran the
Builder who built the wall thousands of
years ago. Another theory is that the man
whom we saw transform into the first
white Walker could be Bran as an adult,
meaning Brand could be the Night King. I don't know
about that, but we'll talk more about the
Night King later. Really, I could talk
about the implications of time travel
for hours, but let's not forget that Bran
is also a warg. He can control the minds
of animals, even magical ones like dire
wolves, and yes, this could mean that we
will see Bran warg into a dragon.
Remember at the end of season 4, the
three-eyed Raven made this cryptic
promise: "You'll never walk again...
but you will fly." Now this could refer
to Brand just flying through a different
winged animal, or like flying through
time in his visions, or just him taking on
the title of the three-eyed Raven,
but yeah, dragon Bran is way cooler. I'm
team Bran-gon. Anyway, let me know in
the comments all the crazy ways that you
want to see Bran use his powers. Let's move
on to another mystery, probably the
biggest mystery on the show now, who is
Azor Ahai reborn aka the prince that was
promised? So the prophecy of Azor Ahai
reborn, also referred to as the prince
was promised, refers to a character
destined to vanquish the White Walkers.
This person is supposed to be born
beneath a bleeding star amidst salt and
smoke, they also carry a flaming sword
called light bringer that was forged in
a unique way, and some interpreters say
that the figure is probably going to be
born from the Targaryen bloodline and
associated with dragons. So obviously the
person who best fits this profile is
Daenerys, but if you care less about the
dragon aspect of it and more about the
sword part of it, Jon Snow could also be
a prime candidate. And then of course I
made another video recently where I
explained that reddit theory that Jaime
Lannister could be Azor Ahai. I've
actually had a series of videos in the
works that makes cases for other
characters. But of course this could just
be the case where we never find out.
George RR Martin has said that he made
Game of Thrones as a response to classic
good versus evil 'chosen one' stories
that glorify war, so this whole prophecy
might just be more interesting as a way
to explore character. Like Stannis
Baratheon was way more compelling as a
man who firmly believed that he was a
prophesied figure but then ultimately
wasn't, and actually the same goes for
Cersei Lannister, who's obsessed with her
own prophecies. So will Cersei's prophecy
be fulfilled? So in the show, Cersei was
told as a girl that she will have three
children with golden hair and golden
shrouds, meaning they'll die prematurely,
and as of the season six finale... check!
Cersei was also told that she would be
queen but that she would be overthrown
by a younger, more beautiful Queen, and at
different points Cersei was paranoid
that could be Sansa, and then later, more
likely, Margaery Tyrell, and then as of
the season six finale... eh, nah. But
obviously there is another younger, more
beautiful Queen on the way who poses a
much bigger threat to Cersei...  Yara
Greyjoy!
I mean, come on, she should be a queen.
Euron Greyjoy is #not my ruler
of the Iron Islands.
No, but seriously Cersei, look out
because Daenerys Targaryen is on her way
to destroy you. But I can honestly see
either of those two powerful women,
Daenerys or Yara, fulfilling Cersei's
prophecy. I also wouldn't count out
either of the Stark girls,
Sansa or Arya. Remember Cersei is still
at the top of Arya's wishlist, and Arya
has proven with Walder Frey that she can
infiltrate castles and assassinate High
Lords and bake their sons into pies.
Now in the books, the prophecy also
includes a bit about Cersei dying at the
hands of the Valonqar - younger brother,
suggesting that Jaime or Tyrion might
end up killing her. Now I've gone over
this a lot actually, go check out our
Jaime Lannister theory video for more
thoughts on that, or just Jaime in
general, and let me know who you think
Azor Ahai reborn will be, and your thoughts
on Cersei's prophecy, and whether Game of
Thrones needs to fulfill these down in
the comments. But let's move on to the
other Lannister sibling, Tyrion. So how
was Tyrion able to face Daenerys' dragons
without getting burned alive? Notice how
the Dragons, Rhaegal and Viserion, seemed
shockingly tame around Tyrion, and we've
speculated in the past that the reason
could be that Tyrion has Targaryen blood
- that's right,
everyone's a Targaryen! So the
interesting theory is that while Tywin
Lannister was hand to the Mad King, the
Mad King could have conceived a child
with Tywin's wife, Joanna Lannister, who
later died giving birth to Tyrion. And
that might further explain why Tywin
always treated Tyrion is less than a son.
It could also explain why Tyrion had
such natural bonds with Jon and Daenerys,
whom he would be related to if this
theory is true. More possible evidence
for this is in the books. In Daenerys'
vision in the house of the undying,
she heard the phrase 'the dragon has
three heads' which you could interpret to
mean that there will be three Targaryens
Daenerys, Jon, and someone else... maybe
Tyrion,
all ridng these three dragons like
their ancestor, Aegon the Conqueror, and
his sisters did during the conquest. And
if you look closely at that final shot
in the season 7 trailer, there does look
like there's a barely noticeable figure
on Drogon's back, and some people said
that could be Tyrion, but then again I
don't know how you would distinguish
what that bump is. Also, earlier in the
trailer there's a shot of Tyrion looking
up as the three dragons
fly past him... I don't know, this could be
foreshadowing something. But comment down
below and let me know what you think
about this theory. Really I'm just
curious to see where Tyrion ends up. I
want him to be on the Iron Throne. I want
him to find that first wife of his, Tysha,
who's still out there somewhere,
and mostly I just want him to finally
get to the punchline of that joke. "I once
brought a jackass and a honeycomb into a
brothel-- I once walked into a brothel
with a honeycomb and a jackass. The madam
says--" But moving on. Another character who's fate I'm curious about is Arya.
Specifically, will Arya ever go west of
Westeros? Remember last season, there was
this almost forgettable moment where
Arya briefly mentions to the actress,
Lady Crane that she might someday like
to explore the West of Westeros. "Essos is East.
Westeros is West, but what's west of
Westeros? I don't know. Nobody does." And
this is pretty interesting, because the
concept of Westeros has been compared in
the past to the countries of Europe, like
England and Scotland, Spain and Italy, and
just like the people that old world used
to wonder about what was on the other
side of the sea - the Americas, what if
there's a whole other world off to the
west of Westeros? Will Arya lead that
global expedition? And since George RR
Martin has said that the world of Game
of Thrones is round, will Arya be the one
to discover that the northern land of
always winter actually connects to the
far eastern part of Essos? I don't know, I
just love maps! I want to see them
filled out. Okay, moving on to someone who
might join Arya on this road trip of
sorts, her direwolf Nymeria. What
happened to Nymeria? Nymeria
disappeared from the show back in season
1, and over the seasons all the other
Stark direwolves have 'dired' off - Lady,
Gray wind, Shaggy-dog and Summer. Now it's
just Jon's direwolf, Ghost, and Nymeria,
wherever she is now. In the books, the
dire wolves have had way more symbolic
significance to the Stark family. They're
smarter, and way larger, and they have
more personality, and they possess
a weirdly magical force. It's actually
kind of implied that all the Stark
children share a telepathic connection
with the animals. Not just Bran, who is
definitely a warg, but Robb and Gray wind
were described
as one and the same on the battlefield,
and in the books, Arya dreams through
Nymeria's eyes as the direwolf leads a
pack of wolves in the Riverlands. Now on the
show, the dire wolves are kind of played
down, they're depicted more as loyal pets
who make us really sad whenever they die.
So will Aria ever see Nymeria again? Will
reuniting with her direwolf be part of an
emotional homecoming sequence, like a
reverse homeward bound? Or will this
reunion be more badass? Like, Arya in the
middle of a battle with White Walkers,
alongside dragon Bran,
discovering her own warg abilities when
her long locst dire wolf appears? I think
I just turned Game of Thrones into
Pokemon. Okay, moving on. The other long
lost Arya companion is Gendry. So where
the hell has Gendry been? And are his arms
super jacked from rowing back and forth
across the Narrow Sea for three seasons?
So Gendry, the blacksmith's apprentice
who is also secretly the bastard son of
Robert Baratheon, was last seen
departing Dragonstone at the end of
season three. And actually, according to
rumors, actor Joe Dempsey has been
spotted in Belfast where Game of Thrones
is shot. And if you look closely at this
shot in the season 7 trailer, I pointed
out how this character is holding a
Warhammer. Now the Warhammer is the
famous weapon of choice by Robert
Baratheon, Gendy's father. So I know
just pointing to a weapon and saying
that's a character is kind of a stretch,
but maybe this is Gendry here, joining
Jon Snow and the others against the
White Walkers. Anyway, let me know in the
comments if you think I'm crazy. Okay,
moving on to two of the most mysterious
figures of Game of Thrones
who are impressively still alive, first
Littlefinger. Specifically, how much
does Littlefinger know? I pointed out in
the past that Littlefinger might know
the truth about Jon's parentage, which
could be why we see Jon shoving
Littlefinger against the wall in the
Winterfell crypts in the trailer, but the
bigger mystery here is how would
Littlefinger know that? I mean, sure, he
does have informants all over Westeros,
but if Littlefinger knew that Ned
Stark's bastard was really the royal son
of Prince Rhaegar Targaryen,
Littlefinger would also probably know
that the whole basis of Robert's
rebellion, Lyanna being kidnapped, was
actually a lie. And this is where I get
paranoid, because we know that it was
Littlefinger who manipulated Lysa Arryn
into
poisoning her husband and then
blaming the Lannisters for the sole
purpose of creating a conflict between
the Lannisters and the Starks
so that little finger could capitalize
on that chaos... "Chaos is a ladder." So what if it was
Littlefinger behind the earlier war as
well, Robert's rebellion? Notice how it
did end up with him climbing the ladder
to become the master of coin. So do you
think Littlefinger could be behind all
of this? Comment, weigh in, let me know. Now
the other mysterious figure that I
mentioned is Varys, and the biggest
question I have about this guy is - what
the hell is going on with that wizard in
a box? Okay don't act like you don't
know what I'm talking about. In season 2,
Varys told Tyrion about the sorcerer
who tortured him as a boy, and how he
later tracked down the old man and kept
him alive in a crate. So we know that
Varys in general looks down on torture
and claims to do everything for the good
of the realm,
specifically the orphan children like he
was. So how does torturing an old wizard
in a wooden crate fit in with all that?
When's he gonna let Dumbledore out of
the box? Okay old man, I'll let you out,
but no funny business. Oh drat,
he truned himself into a chicken.
Why did I do this?
So another mystery that I'm curious
about involves the religions of Westeros.
Which of these many gods is the true God?
Now we've seen several different faiths on
the show, and more than one of them have
shown their own kind of divine power.
There are the old gods, who are still
worshipped in the North. They've been kind
of legitimized now that their weirwood
trees, the three-eyed Raven, and the
children of the forest all have shown to
have legit magic. Meanwhile, the followers
of the Lord of Light, the monotheistic
religion from Essos, have successfully
resurrected more than one person from
the dead, so I would also say that's a
miracle.
Then there's the drowned god of the Iron
Islands, who also has had some kind of
resurrection power. Remember, every time
they baptize someone, they're technically
drowning them first. Then there's the
many-faced God of the faceless men, who
seemed mystic and divine at first, but
now we know that that magic is based
more on sleight of hand and superfast
wardrobe changes. Now the most
traditional and widespread of these
religions in Westeros is the new gods
(the seven), but they, along with the
Dothraki worship of the great stallion,
kind of went up in smoke... literally. And
then there's this obscure deity that
Varys brought up one time:
"In the summer isles, they worship the fertility goddess with
16 tits."
Sounds legit to me. So I'm curious to see
how the two currently most powerful
religions on the show, the Lord of Light
and the old gods, are reconciled.
Specifically there's so much we don't
know about characters like Kinvara, the
High Priestess of the Lord of Light.
There's also that mysterious Riddler
character from the same city that can
Kinvara's from,  Asshai, but her name was
Quathe, the shadow binder. Does she have
any connection to the Lord of light? Is
she ever coming back? Could you tell us
how she made that awesome mask? We'd
actually love to make another video
that dives deep into all these different
religions on the show, but in the
meantime, let me know what you think in
the comments. And moving on to the final
big unresolved mystery of Game of
Thrones, what exactly do the White
Walkers want? So last season we finally
got some big information about the White
Walkers, or the others as they're known
the books. They were created by the
children of the forest as a white weapon
of mass destruction during the war with
men. So we now know how they were created,
but what do they hope to achieve? Or do
they just have no goals other than they
kill everything in sight like evil ice
terminators? Sure, it does seem like Game
of Thrones is heading towards an epic
battle of good versus evil, with the men
finally joining forces to face off
against these supernatural weapons of
war. But now that I say that, I feel like
the George RR Martin version of that war
would end with like the white walkers
just winning and the Night King sitting
on the Iron Throne and getting his balls
stuck to it. So thinking outside of the
box, and all the other alternate ways
this could go, the theory that makes the
most sense to me is that the Night
King's goal is to do what every
artificial instrument of destruction
inevitably does - meet his maker and
destroy him. So how would the Night King
destroy the children of the forest? Like,
aren't they all already dead? Well, maybe
not. According to legend in the middle of
the Gods Eye lake is the Isle of faces. Now
this is a sacred historical site where
the children the forest and men agreed
to the pact that ended their war. The
island is supposed to be covered in
weirwood trees and no one goes there
other than a group of caretakers called
the green men. And I think that some
remaining children of the forest might
be there, too. And this could be
where the night king and his white
walker army are headed, to finish off the
children of the forest. In fact, that might
be why the White Walkers keep making
this spiral pattern in the snow, which
remember, reflects the pattern of these
stones surrounding the weirwood tree
where the Night King was created. It could
be a warning from the Night King that he
remembers the day that the children of
the forest doomed him to this life of
endless torment. And now that I'm looking
at the shots, I'm wondering if this
weirwood tree where the Night King was
created might be on the Isle of faces,
and maybe Bran's second vision of it,
where it was all frozen over, is a look
into the future when winter has covered
all of Westeros in ice, which could
happen in season seven and eight, and
maybe the White Walkers have returned to
their original home, smack in the middle
of Westeros. Okay, okay, fair enough, I may
have pushed you too far with that theory.
There's just so much mystery with White
Walkers and my mind is going to weird
places. But what do you think the White
Walkers end goal is? And what other
unresolved questions do you want to see
answered in these final two seasons? And
also remember to weigh in on those other
questions about Jon, Bran, Azor Ahai,
Cersei, Tyrion, Arya and all the rest, and
get your friends to weigh in on this
stuff, too. You can like this video and
share it around, and you can tweet any
thoughts or questions to me directly
(@eavoss) or at new rockstars (@newrockstars). This channel is actually going to
start doing some giveaways on Twitter, so
make sure to follow us and of course
subscribe to new rockstars. We've got some
really great game of Thrones content
in the works -  you're gonna love it. And you
can actually have a say in what videos
we make here by contributing to us on
patreon. Thank you so much to all of our
current patrons, especially Wilhelmina
Ebbison. Okay thanks for watching - Damn
it!
Varys's box wizard got out again. I was
getting him the food, Varys, this is on
you!